ces 4
je m'appelle mini jeux tom schoewe je
dis ce que je veux 24 heures sur 24 il
est dur ce fait
nouveau loge assure mais j'ai pas le
temps de m'amuser caisse de quantum et
booster
c'est pas facile tous les jours tu as
vrai
[Musique]
tabac est la meilleure amie vous tous ma
vie et rien ni personne ne m'arrêtera
[Musique]
mes e-mails le petit déjeuner est prêt
j'arrive
est ce qu'on m'avait mais
[Musique]
a bien suivi
ne regardez pas laissez moi j'arrive
déjà ouah qu'est ce que tu as dit
les ancêtres avaient un lien mystique
avec les pandores non mais c'est
pourquoi c'est une petite excentricité
dans notre famille
[Musique]
chance on dirait coluche est horrible
contador mais la sueur
au temps voilà
n'importe quelle émotion forte mais va
libérer le banc barbie 30 mois
non
tu réalises à quel point c'est dangereux
sécurité mais on va fêter le panda
assuré
[Musique]
je ne crois pas
toute ma vie j'étais l'âge aussi fait
que payer
tous les sens plutôt bien autant d'à
papapapa pauvres chéris banane
ce qu'on m'avait mail